Video game culture needs to stop fetishizing skill.
*Laughs*
Crybabies!
The physical glass ceiling when they get good mentality turns ableist
*Laughs*
*Laughs/Cries*
Have you played "I wanna be the guy"?
Have you played? it have you played it? if so, did you make it past the first...
screen? My name is PewDiePie. I'm on a mission to beat this game based on my wonderful comments
that are supporting me on this journey.
*Magical melodies*
Here we go! I've only died three three three times. Oh my god. That's half the devil times
I don't even remember how to play..
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're here.
Fine, it can't be that bad.
Great
Actually? nevermind. I forgot about that one all right. I know how to make it there
Oh There's a bird. There's a bird. What do I do?
Stop Stop Stop!
You goddamn bird
Stop!
STOP!
STOOOP!!
Fuck
Pace Magazine and polygon they were right. Games journalism was right.
They were right all along
I don't understand...
There's so many steps. I have to jump this one, gotta watch out for them
And then the Apple, and then the third. And it's like...
Oh My God!
Okay. Look at this perfect. Fir...
I'm gonna do it. I'm gonna do this on the first try
First try baby come on
Zero deaths, and then you walk back and then forward then...
First try okay. You do the jump
Then you walk back, then forward and then back
You do the first jump...
You do the first jump. You gotta wait for the timing
You gotta wait for the timing, Do the... right. And then you gotta walk back, then forward, then back e..
You got to do the first jump...
You got to do the first jump, wait for the timing, you go in back and back and forth and...
You got to do the first jump, right...
First jump..
Oh I get it. Oh okay. I see, first try, okay, so..
First jump
Stand there, and then you go back. I got it! look at that
How easy that is, once you know how to do it
And I didn't even watch a mexican... goddamnit. So you gotta jump up here. Watch out for... fucking bird!
And then all the apples. All the apples. Okay...
And the zombies at the same time, at the same time, you got it at the same time
come on
Easy
Easy! Now. Now, more birds. That's fine. That's fine
There's birds everywhere in life. You just gotta deal with it alright. Okay here. It comes here. It comes
*slap*
COME ON!
Here we go, come on
Get hyped, get hyped
Come on! x9
Fuktchu
Fuck you
Fu...
*Slams keyboard*
*Imitating* "Cuphead is so difficult"
"I don't know what t..."
*slams table*
I don't understand this jump. I just don't understand it. You have to understand the jump, to make the jump!
You can't just jump! You have to know the jump. You have to breathe the jump. You have to be the...
Godd...
Come ooon!
Wait for the right moment Felix, wait for the right moment
Your time and will arise. Young child. Young child. Your time will come
Oohh
*moans*
Now
No
Run
Faaan...
Look at this perfect skills, jump?
Alright, look at this goddamn perfect skills we do the... f..
Look at these goddamn perfect skills
We do the first jump...
We go here
When wait for the dangle, we jump
perfect timing
Now we watch out for the claw, and now we prepare ourself for the bird, we shoot the bird, first apple. Not a problem
Shoot the zambies. Shoot the zambies. Watch out for apples, keep shooting zambies, more apples, more zambies
What are you gonna do zambies? One other one. Another one. Oh it's good
Oh he celebrates, but never! He's gotta shoot all the birds..
He's gotta shoot all the birds. He waits patiently for his right time. Just kidding! He goes for it!
He goes through all of it.
*grunts twice*
He does it perfectly, but he only has one chance to blow
eh
Argh! That was so.. fduhu. Can't you just go up?
*Cries*
He cries like a little baby
NO!
Oh this is not good
*Focused Pewds*
Yes!
Uh!
*Laughts*
*He's going insane*
F...
What now? What now? What are you gonna do? You know that shit's not gonna let me go there
*exhales*
Come on! I'm gonna count down from five...
Five..
Four...
Three...
Two...
It's a, it's a, it's a, it's a bird. I can, i ca.. It's gonna be a bird
One...
Are you fucking stupid?
What was that?
*sad flute*
I didn't even jump it. I didn't even jump it
*Pewds going insane* I didn't even jump it
How about that?
Whoaho!
Looks like we have to do all this again!
*chill drums*
*chill music*
Took a little break. Watch me, watch me do this on the first try.
Watch me do it on first try
First try watch me do it. Watch me do it on first try. First try watch me
do it. First try, first try, first try watch me do it. Come on! First try, first try, first try
First try, first try mother...truckers. BIRD! First try...
First try is easy
EASY...
*screaming* EASY...
E... E... E
*Yells*
First try! First try. Come on! Come on!
*Speechless Pewds*
*Insane Pewds*
Fucking piece of shit!
*Angry Pewds*
That doesn't even make any sense
Why did it move?
Why did it go down?
First try! Come on!
*mumbles* Foam.. Fukskd i gotta fuck you unless you got
Brrraah
First try! First try! Zero deaths, zero deaths, zero deaaa...
Zero...
ZERO DEATHS!
ZERO...
How many deaths?
zero
serah
SERA
*singing* "Wherever you be, you be" serah!
Serah, sera, zero deaths, sera, sera, zero deaths, sera...
*Continues into "beatboxing"*
brrrrah
pah x16
pah x6
Pwah
*yells*
ZERO
ZER...
NOOOOO...
*child-like voice*
B, But i went back?..
But I went back!
I can do this!
I'm Felix (Mother Flipping) Kjellberg. Christian Channel. I respect wamen and dead memes. Thank you
Thank you very much. Come on!
You fuckka bakka makka.
Come on! x2
Come on dude...
Come on! x3
Get hyped. Get fucking hyped
Come on, come on, come on. Oh, oh.
That was some terrible timing
*game music playing*
YES! YES! Suck my Swedish. Brrrahhpa
*Pewds celebrating*
"You're gonna make this Felix. You're gonna make this. You're gonna make this Felix. You're gonna make this.."
GO
*Rage Pewds*
*chill music*
*Focused Pewds*
Yes, oh
Okay please!
Please, come on. I'm so... This took me 15 minutes. It took me 15 minutes to get back here. 15 minutes!
Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me?
*clap*
Yes!
YES!
YEEEES!
Tsfuu...
Mnaah!..
*Exhaling violently*
Goodbye. leave a like!
BRRAAH